miami-dade county commissioner has said
51 residents are unaccounted for
after the 12-story building came down in
the early hours of this morning
a major rescue operation is underway to
find anyone who may be trapped
under the rubble let's cross live now to
sky correspondent martha kellner who's
in washington dc for us
i mean they are pictures of devastation
there
in miami martha what do we know has
happened
yeah total devastation sarah you can see
from those pictures
that building collapse happened just
after 2 a.m
local time in that apartment building in
the surf side area of florida which is
just north
of miami beach and it's a fairly large
apartment block
and it's home to around 103 131 units
apologies
and and it's thought that 81 of those
units were actually occupied at the time
we know that one person has died and but
there still
are 51 residents unaccounted for the
pictures that you can see there are one
entire side
of this apartment block the local mayor
described it as being absolutely
pancaked they were completely
flattened it must have been terrifying
for the residents of that building and
local buildings
as that happened while many of them were
asleep
and we know that 35 people have been
rescued
by emergency services from that
collapsed building
although we think they've been mainly
rescued and from those
balconies that you can see on the part
of the building that is still standing
using cherry pickers there was picture
that i think and local tv
had of one young boy being rescued by
firefighters
and he looks to be a young teenager he
was dragged from that rubble
and rescued by firefighters hoisted over
the arm of
one of the firefighters but obviously
very worrying that there are still
51 people unaccounted for